[Music]
so some
bobby lee was asked
i guess by ryan sickler again not really
sure who that is but
how his relationship has been with uh
with brian callan
post the whole you know breakup thing
i want to do
the next chapter of my life which i feel
like is my final chapter you know i
don't know how many chapters i have but
you know but
for the rest of my life i wanna
you know
i wanna do it
the best way i can i hate it i i i know
i therapy talk
yeah you this is exactly what i was
going to say like i know that i say it a
lot and and i do i know i understand
that i say it a lot but but
it's this la
[ __ ] therapy gobbledygook these guys
always start with always my second half
i just started this is bobby lee sounds
like a woman that would post him like
did you know morgan freeman didn't
become famous until his 50s like one of
those things were like your life isn't
over it's just starting stop jesus
christ all these other comic talks like
motivational posters
it's all this therapy to talk it's what
it is
healthy way
it's interesting um uh the ghost
when i worked for uh oprah you worked
for oprah i did i worked for oprah
winfrey yeah no no no oprah smith
what [ __ ] oprah is it gonna be bobby
i'm not familiar with the oprah who
dr phil's friend oh oh yeah yeah the
black chick yeah
only one bro i don't know i don't know
for william
wait you were for oprah winfrey yeah
right here in l.a when she started her
network owned the oprah winfrey network
yeah i was uh you ever talked to her i
met her one time yeah twice i met her um
i went and um
and
calen
for here
right
or care is that
is
i don't have a problem with brendan
schaub
you're in the minority
right
or callan or these guys you know i mean
i've known brian callan
for
over 20 years you know i mean we're from
the same show i mean he was on mad tv
before me but we're a part of that
family right so it's like i've been to
brian's house you know i mean i've hung
out with those guys many many times
right i was just setting up let me guess
did it uh and i'm gonna assume that's
how it went you showed up to their house
and then they picked on you and bullied
you the entire time you were there
busted your chops and be like no i'm
just kidding man you know i like you
is that what happened bobby because i
kind of feel like that's yeah
a boundary for myself because they were
saying crazy things that had nothing to
do with right hope someday i might see
him at something i hope when i see him
maybe i can hug him and hold him until
he forgives me or maybe i can or maybe i
can make it up to him i was like you
know maybe maybe bobby if bobby maybe
you could tattoo something on me and and
that way we can be friends whatever i
got by the way i know we've mentioned
this before but it's hilarious that
brian callum thinks the way after compl
accusing your friend of such a horrific
thing that you could make it up by doing
a 90 a 90 stern radio stunt
what are you east side dave i was going
to say it's very much a shock chalk
radio stunt to make up for betraying you
as a friend
this whole thing has gone out of control
though because there's love between i
love us bobby and he doesn't call me and
he doesn't and i get it i i [ __ ] hurt
him and i just think it was mishandled
all the way around it's gotten to the
point where we have to address it which
you know me i don't like addressing this
stuff the world yeah but sometimes you
have to tell the truth and when i [ __ ]
up i own it uh when i [ __ ] up uh you
know i i i don't have any problem
telling the truth and i don't have any
it's awful i'm going to
you know i just told them don't you know
normally these guys i would let people
talk to me in that way right
because in comedy obviously you know
that there are people that are
not like you like you and i i think are
more similar in terms of like yeah i
could feel the electricity in this yeah
the chemistry in this interview it's
[ __ ] fire off the charts jesus christ
our sensibilities you know i mean we're
a little sensitive no very yeah very
sensitive and we're um
you know asian facial hair is the worst
yeah it's not great little soft
creatures
right and there are other people that
are like more dominant why are you
admitting to being a little soft
creature like why would you be proud of
being a beta like i that i don't
understand you know
alpha e right
and so it's like i usually just absorb
that [ __ ] but i'm like because of the
shift that you're talking about i just
basically said hey man don't talk to me
like that because i didn't do anything
right and um
we're done
why can't i do that as a human being you
can that's what i'm saying to another
human being so that's all it happened
but people online are like saying like
it's a war or there's a there's a
division there is no division right you
literally said you don't want a calendar
to ever be on your show again you never
want to talk to him what are you talking
about sounds pretty
like pretty bobby much like division
which by the way i'm fine with if you
want to tell them the [ __ ] off never
come on that's fine but don't you can't
say something like that and then the
next and your next breath be like we're
cool we're cool i'm never going to see
merch again but we're cool
everything's fine i hate his cook
come hear me i'll shoot him i'll kill
him but we're cool
i filed a restraining order protective
order but we're cool everything's fine
haters pumpkin i'm talking i hate her
opie never go full opie
guy that says i don't want to be talked
to in that way i didn't do anything
right it was
just out of left field it was just it
was very traumatic
you're an adult man traumatic
and i don't need to
take that yeah my producer kirsten is on
the [ __ ] she's got her finger on the
pulse of everything podcasting and she
was telling me all the stuff that was
going on so i watched is he sleepy
i don't know who ryan sickler is but he
tired or something does he need a nap
it's just his or he's just naturally
like this
i mean oh i'm hey
i used to rock with oprah
yeah my producer man just really keeps
your fingers on the pulse
i just i watched your episodes and i've
talked to other comedians about it as
well and you've been pretty maybe he's
so tired because he has spent all his
traveling money and dan flashes that's
what it is yeah you can't get it you
can't you're not going to eat yeah
that's what happens but you know it's
very complicated patterns it is it is
you know they had a shirt that cost two
thousand dollars you said it was one
thousand dollars i shut the [ __ ] up mark
honest about everything out there yeah
so i don't blame you one bit and i saw
friends we were at a wedding together
and i um
who's what you were each like you were
the don't say you were at a wedding
together this sounds like remember that
movie was was it kevin james and adam
sandler got married
so they could get insurance chucking
larry whatever yeah
dude [ __ ]
don't bobby don't say it that way it
makes you sound you're a giga like if me
and royce were attending the same
wedding i'd be like oh i was at this
wedding royce was at the same wedding
and we were talking i wouldn't say we
went to we were at a wedding together
i would be like mercer and i were the
same wedding and we had sex with each
other that would still sound less good
we're not married that would still sound
less gay than we were at a wedding
together
you know he was getting coffee
and i walked outside i swear to god does
bobby have a dramamine patch so he
doesn't get carsick in the uber there
like what's it for
what are you a sailor
what are you doing are you on a cruise
ship is this podcast on a cruise ship is
ryan's sickler show on a carnival cruise
ship he's like one of those um
he's like one of those [ __ ] dogs that
gets like [ __ ] motion sick in a car
yeah i know do you need a thunder coat
bobby
to my go what'd you get
oh you guys i gotta ice what are you
gonna get
yeah i mean i go
i'm gonna get a double espresso you know
i'm
espresso not that him and i ever gonna
get back to the place but it's like
i i feel like there's
but
you know what makes this weirder and i
don't know maybe i'm wrong right
now you're now you're on a podcast
talking about a small interaction you
had with somebody at a wedding
and you're like
it's not about getting back at this
place the problem with them is that a
lot of these la comics use their like
personal life as content for their show
like they're just most everything
personal about them that's her show and
it's like man i get it i guess it gets
views but like i don't know
then you complain that the internet's
making fun of your personal life then
don't make it your entire show bobby
you know
well that was like a work function you
were performing yeah i'm trying to
figure it out yeah i'm so excited
[ __ ] sounds like mr plinkett over
here you know i mean i'm i'm trying to
figure it out but um yeah boundaries are
nice i love that brendan frog
gringo poppy was the worst comedy
special i've ever seen
like i don't allow it you know but um
that's all it is you know i mean it was
like um i did i never had a problem with
those guys i love those guys in fact one
of my most viral things when it comes to
podcasting is on fighter the kid it's
like still out there you know i mean
it's a very funny bit i mean how do you
define suck in a day no like a penis in
your mouth
i mean there was that time in college
did you i went to a phase where i was
gay uh no i never have never had a dick
in my mind love you bobby
bobby
oh i remember this story
i'm gonna again skip this segment
because i don't really
care about the bobby lee dick thing
i don't know man it was i wish it never
happened but
and did that by the way who whoever is
clipping this
pretty funny good job intersplicing the
other stories just to get over that
10-minute mark for monetization
my relationship with yeah i'm not saying
that sarcastically that was very
honestly a good move
you know it's it did
you mean a lot of that stuff affected it
it kind of um
put more fuel on something that you know
i mean that didn't need more fuel right
you know and um that was already having
problems yeah yeah i could tell you
could tell by how exciting i am
i does this guy right maybe is that what
i'm hearing maybe steven right
that might be the and also could i i i'm
trying to hold a revolving door open for
a woman
broke both my arms
thanks buddy
well's already having problems i think
maybe a year from now maybe i don't know
i mean maybe i'll realize that kawhila's
the one for me and i'll we'll get back i
don't know
who knows what will happen but it sounds
like she's still gonna be right next to
you on the bed yeah yeah and we're i'm i
sleep we sleep great and
we communicate and um there's a lot of
crying and a lot
it sounds wonderful to live that life
there's a lot of crying
a lot of um
growing up that we're doing you know and
it's you know really it's tough but um
like i said man um i don't know what's
gonna happen i know also that's another
thing it's like i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm not
you know i don't want to live in the
results of anything
you know it's like i don't want to live
in the results of anything is absolutely
a therapist line that he's repeating of
course
100 everything these people says is just
parroting stuff they're therapists
because they think it makes them sound
deep
i'm not a fortune teller really you're
asian
you know i can't foresee i could die in
here i don't know what's gonna happen
right but it's like the most important
thing is obviously the moment and um
the here and now all right eminem
and i just need to
live in this space you know because
that's another therapist
living this space live in this space is
not something normal human people say to
each other
that's something a jewish guy with horn
rim glasses such to you why he says same
time next week you have to find a better
space yeah for yourself my whole life
i've never lived here
i've never lived in the moment
everything was like what is it you know
how come this guy got that and how how
can i get that and what if this happens
and that it's just like not living
you're cool
here's the thing he's going through this
reinvention but he doesn't realize that
at the end of the day when it's all said
and done he's still just bobby lee
like this isn't like a great actor going
through a reinvention this isn't like
daniel day lewis going like i'm gonna
i'm changing everything up that i'm
doing reinvention like oh man what's
danny lewis going to do next he's such a
great actor it's like
bobby i don't care
yeah i mean he's got to be these people
have these therapists that rob them
blind and they never tell them straight
up that the thing they need to do
is just
learn to be okay with the fact that you
are who you are and you're gonna die and
we're all nobody
and plow through that get okay with that
as you can tell mercy used to be a
hallmark card writer
you're going to die
and everyone who ever knew you will and
someday no but but that's the front of
the card and then
after you read that when you open up the
card all you hear is
ah there it is happy 40th there it is
um
so yeah it's just therapist mumbo jumbo
oh maybe you're a big act together i'm
gonna live in the moment these are
comedians
this is the comedy scene